what the hell people why why do you hate
shalon
[Music]
halt i do not hate shalon davar shalon
is one of my favorite characters i
thought that her character in words of
radiance
was fantastic i even enjoyed her in
the way of kings that's not what this
video is about this video isn't about my
personal
taste what i actually want to talk about
today is
shalon's character in the way of kings i
have read
countless people talking about how
shalon is their waste
how shalon is their least favorite
character i kind of came in with that
preconception that okay well shalon is
going to be my least favorite character
because everyone else seems to not be
terribly fond of her but
i really enjoyed reading her chapters
however
this got me thinking i wanted to really
figure out why in the hell
people didn't like shalon what made
people less interested in her than they
were in kaladin
and in dalinar and why that is when on
the surface she's a very interesting
character but why
within this story within the way of
kings why were people not interested
i think there are a few interesting
conclusions before i get into my
analysis
if you aren't subscribed consider
clicking the like button because
gosh golly g i do appreciate it this is
going to be a
spoiler dive into the way of kings i
will not be spoiling
words of radiance or anything but way of
kings spoilers
[Music]
as kind of a writer myself i
am interested in what makes sanderson's
characters tick
he has put out a massive amount of
lectures and interviews and so much
about how he writes his methods and is
such an
excellent teacher in one of his lectures
and he's probably talked about this
multiple times he talks about
why readers often dislike certain
characters not because there's something
wrong with them but because they grow a
bond with
one character over another and i think
this is part of the issue of
writing an epic series with multiple
characters in different places who
aren't interacting because you're
jumping around between
different stories and in the way of
kings is really not apparent how any of
these characters are connected until the
end
so in a sense you're jumping between
very
very vaguely connected people in that
sense you start to
become attached to one character over
another in the way of kings people
usually get attached to paladin because
we're with him the longest
we see his backstory the book is really
about caledon
mostly shalon and dalinar are kind of in
the wings
building up their story to what's going
to become their important
moments my first point is is pacing
sanderson
has made this point in his lectures when
you are tearing
readers away from their favorite
characters to go focus on another
character
it can be rough i think that sanderson
gets better with his
later books in in doing this but in the
way of kings it seemed particularly
rough
when things were getting just so juicy
and interesting with caledon or with
dalinar and
we get pulled away to shalon who is in a
drastically
less hostile situation when you're going
from kaladin
getting shot at getting beaten the [ __ ]
out of him wondering if he's going to
survive to
shalon going hmm i wonder if i should
steal
this soulcaster i wonder hmm
let me illustrate it this way for the
first hundred pages we are dealing with
shalon and kaladin it's only when we get
to page 102 in the mass market paperback
where we learn about what shalon's plan
is
so that first section we are seeing
shalon explore
car brand in kind of painful detail we
learn about the
crew of the ship which is unnecessary
extra
not super important and and she's trying
to become the student of this great
teacher
yazna colin but when we get to the real
juicy part that great line
that ends shalon's section and then
shalon would steal it
talking about the soulcaster which is
like
what so that's shalon's mission and we
think okay this is going to be really
interesting i really want to see her
steal this [ __ ] soulcaster that's
page 102.
she doesn't steal the soulcaster until
page 666.
she slid the working soulcaster into her
safe hand within its sleeve stepping
back as yazna
opened her eyes and glanced at the robe
which now sat innocently beside the
non-functional soulcaster
obviously we're dealing with a lot of
other stuff in that sequence
in those 600 pages we're dealing with
kaladin
and dalinar and their situations are
considerably higher stakes
most of what shalon is going through in
in those pages and we don't see her too
often but when we do she's
talking with yasna having discussions
about philosophy
which is interesting but it can be
frustrating especially because she's
we're with her for so much time trying
to decide
when how or even if she should steal the
soulcaster
at some point you just get so frustrated
with her progression because
these other characters you have a sense
of progress all the time but shalon
just feels kind of stuck sanderson talks
about this in his
his lectures a lot about you need a
sense of progress for people to stay
interested in the story and shalon makes
very very very very
slow progress when stealing the
soulcaster until finally she just
makes a snap decision and then for the
rest of the book it gets more
interesting because she has the
soulcaster she's afraid of getting
caught she's making progress
in trying to figure out how to use the
soulcaster in the first half she's just
trying to decide if she should do the
thing that she knows she has to do
and sanderson has some really jarring
moments of
jumping between really high stakes
almost
like cliffhanger moments after kaladin
fails
the sideways bridge method he's getting
the [ __ ] kicked out of him
the chapter ends with just the soldiers
kept kicking and it's like oh my god
this character who you care about so
much
you want to know what the [ __ ] is going
to happen and then the immediate next
chapter
is about shalon in the palladium
the library it's just long descriptions
the information the parchment trying to
unravel the mystery and yeah that that
is interesting on its own but when
you're jumping from this
incredibly high stakes life or death
situation to um
let me discover this and i'm still
trying to figure out if i should steal
the soulcaster or not etc i see why
people would start to resent shalon
not because she's a bad character but
just because of the way she is
taking time from the characters that
we're a little more invested in at the
moment
there are other things going on she
starts to fall in love with capsule
that [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] capsule
oh my god a lot of people don't like
those romance scenes i realized i
actually liked it
i liked capsule you know i thought well
she kept thinking there's something
weird about him i'm like you know give
the guy a chance he seems like a great
guy
he seems like a perfectly swell fellow i
started to like their romance a little
bit you know the jam was cute and
everything
boy was i [ __ ] wrong with that shalon
story got super interesting at the very
end of the book
that's when everything got interesting
honestly her motivation was very
singular and wasn't progressing in
very clear ways
the elephant in the room the reason why
people complain about shalon the most
is the humor there are cringe moments
shalon is sometimes cringe but i think
more of the issue
isn't so much with the humor but with
loaded dialogue especially when she's
trying to be quippy
i didn't think the quips were
necessarily bad or the humor but the
amount of words used when delivering the
humorous lines it seemed unnecessary
almost like
sanderson was trying to write her as
being excessively formal
i think he kind of sheds that quality a
little bit later
in the books like in words of radiance
that's a little bit less there and she's
a little
less formal in her quips the humor i
think you know it's just kind of like
okay you either think it's
cute and clever or whatever and you let
it go or makes you cringe and makes you
stop
in your tracks i didn't have that
experience with her dialogue sometimes
the conversations would just run
on overstay its welcome and feel a
little bloated characters would say
things in more words than they needed to
now that i'm reading oathbringer i mean
it's it's really a huge improvement
in terms of how he's writing this
dialogue that's my impression of it you
know i'm curious to hear from people who
really dislike shalon who think that
she's just a drag on the series i i'm
curious
of what you have to say maybe there's
more to shalon that's i won't enjoy an
oath ringer i don't know i personally
think that shalon is a fantastic
character i thought that her arc
in words of radiance was beautiful and
wonderful
she is probably my favorite character in
the series
except for lyft am i right liv what the
hell people
why why do you hate shalon these are my
theories i'd be interested to hear what
other people have to say the video the
video is done now